So, as I sit down to eat from this spread that has been given in my honor, I can't help
but notice the two feelings that I'm having.
One, I'm a little nervous.
Two, I'm very excited because you see, in the morning, I'll be paroling from state prison
after 26 years.
The spread is given to me, not as like to say, hey, homie, we appreciate you.
No, it was a spread to say, we don't never want to see your ass in here again.
And they broke out the finest of the finest, top ramen, chili in a can, roast beef in
a can, you know, this top line of stuff, right?
So, after the spread has been had, it's time for me to give away some property, such as
my TV, my radio, and some self-help books that help me a lot, so they'll be better utilized
left behind.
Nine o'clock rolls around, it's lights out.
You don't have to go to sleep, but you do got to get off the day room floor.
It's cool about me, I'm leaving in the morning.
So, I may have gotten like three hours worth of sleep that night.
I slept ready roll, and that means I slept with my clothes on.
Soon as they call my name, I'm out of there.
Bye, see you later.
So 545 rolls around, the night man says, Cyprian D37-875, report to R&R.
I walked down that corridor for the last time, walked through one gate after another till
I get to R&R, and that's receiving and release, and I'm on the release end at this point.
I get to R&R, and there's about seven to six other guys waiting for the same thing.
They start fingerprinting me, mug shots, and everything, I'm cool, like, time to go.
So they load us onto a van, and we drive through one gate after another gate, till we get to
the final gate.
The cop says, all right, everybody off the van, you'll step to the man at the base of
the tower there, and you'll give him some personal information.
So we did, and he gave each man an envelope with $200 in it, better known as gate money.
We all got back onto the van and drove through that last gate.
We made it around to the visitor's parking lot, and he asks, is there anyone with a ride?
I do.
I was the only one to get off the van.
These other guys, that $200 gate money, they had to spend it on buying their bus tickets,
maybe back to Southern California or even further up north, but I was the lucky one.
My wife was waiting there.
With her camera, I could see her, she was snapping pictures of me like a paparazzi.
I walked briskly towards her, gave her a quick kiss, whispered it in her ear, let's get out
of here before they say we made a mistake.
We got in the car, drove away, I saw a 7-Eleven, I was like, hey babe, pull over, I want to
go in and get something.
So I went in and grabbed a pack of Big Red gum.
I hadn't had chewing gum in 26 years.
Big Red was my favorite.
We got back in the car, drove away, we were on the road for about 30 to 45 minutes.
I spotted a Target.
I said, hey babe, that's Target, I saw that on the TV, pull over, I want to go in there.
So we did.
The first thing that caught my eye was how big the shopping basket was.
It was bigger than the space that I had to store my personal property while in prison.
I grabbed the basket and went down the aisle grabbing various things such as underwear,
socks, t-shirt, toothbrush, toothpaste, you name it, I grabbed it.
Well, that goes at $200 gate money.
So back in the car, and my wife says, so what do you want for dinner?
She stumped me with that one.
Because for 26 years, no one had ever asked me, what do I want for dinner?
My dinner came through a 13 by 13 hole in the wall.
You stick your hand in there and pull out a tray and what's ever on there, that's what
you eat.
So she says, I know what to fix.
So she drove, we made it to the grocery store, went into the grocery store.
This gigantic store, Berkeley Bowl.
So I made it to the produce section.
I'm stuck.
There are so many oranges to choose from.
And the reason I'm stuck just looking at the oranges is because for the past 10 years in
prison, they had taken oranges away from us because they were used to make wine.
So there's like a bumpy orange, a smooth orange, a naval orange.
I even met my first blood orange.
And at the same time, this wave hit me of alone and feeling like, I don't know, a nervous
feeling hit me like I'm the only person in this store who's paroled from a prison today
after 26 years.
I'm a little stuck and a little, ooh.
So I'm looking around and I spot this ink work.
It's not the typical ink work that I see out here now.
Like what color?
No, I know this ink work.
This is prison ink.
He has a prison guard tower on him, a melted clock with time.
I know that work.
I've seen that many times.
So I walk over to him and I whisper, so what yard did you parole from?
He said, oh me?
I got, I paroled from Pelican Bay like four months ago.
I'm like, and they know you got out of prison?
They know you're on parole?
Oh yeah, they're not tripping here.
This is Berkeley, man.
Nobody's tripping.
Well I walked away from him with the understanding that if he can get a job, so can I.
So I met my wife at the checkout.
Once again, there's another stunned moment for me.
There are 12 checkout lines and there's somebody on the other end bagging the groceries.
In prison, there was one window, maybe 13 by 13 again, and there was like 300 guys waiting
to get into this one window with their lists.
I didn't have to worry about an alarm going off or anything, no getting down.
We're going to get our groceries and leave out of here.
That was my thought.
Cool.
So we made it through the checkout, went back to the car, got in the car and we're on the
road and we come to a stoplight.
And this homeless guy had a sign that says, anything will help.
So my wife reaches into the cup holder and gets ready to hand him some change.
And all of a sudden he gets a phone call.
And he tells my wife, wait, I got to get this.
And my thoughts were like, if he got a cell phone, I got to get one.
So we drive away and my wife, she just drives real fast, right?
And we make it to the neighborhood just as fast as we got to the store and she pulls
into the neighborhood and she points out the various neighbors house.
This is where Fred and Mike live.
The brewers live here.
And I'm like, OK, and we get to our house.
And she said, and this is us.
We live at the edge of the forest.
Like, cool, cool.
And so we went inside and she gives me the grand tour.
And so she says, well, I'm going to prepare this dinner.
I said, cool.
So she made steak and lobster with small potatoes.
Nothing out of a can, folks.
Nothing out of a packet either.
She made this meal.
We sat down.
We ate.
And I had my first glass of wine with my meal.
I'm not saying I've never had wine before.
I've never had wine with a meal.
This is some grown folks shit, I thought.
Right?
So after the meal was finished, we're cleaning up, washing dishes.
My wife says, you want to get further acclimated?
I'm like, yeah.
She said, take out the garbage.
No problem.
I reach down, tie that garbage bag up, throw it over my shoulder,
and out to the front door I go.
When I open up the door, no more than eight feet away from me
was a 10-point buck just standing there, looking at me,
looking at it, staring at me.
Now, had we been on a prison yard,
me and his buck would have had issues.
Now, I speak a lot of different gangster languages.
I'm fluent in Crip.
I understand blood.
I even speak a little ese cholo vato loco.
But I don't speak deer.
So I shut the door.
I called out to my wife.
I said, hey, babe, there's somebody here to see you.
She came to the door, opened it, and saw there was the buck.
She grabbed the trash bag and walked right past it.
I said, damn, she speaks deer.
She came back, and we both look out the door
together at this buck who's still standing there,
just looking just majestic as could be.
And my wife says, you don't need to trip him.
He's just one neighbor coming to welcome you to the neighborhood.
Cool.
I thought, well, the fellas aren't
going to believe this shit when I tell them this.
I met my first deer.
I met my first blood orange.
I had my first glass of wine with my meal.
This is my first day of my new life.
What's tomorrow going to bring me?
Thank you.